we've all heard stories of the Oliver
Stone's the Colonel Sanders and more
that make it past a certain age and
especially in in an industry where so
many people say hey give it up if you
haven't quote-unquote made it by 30 what
do you think arnelle's story represents
to everyone about making it past a
certain age when especially in an
industry that's so obsessed with looks I
have known musicians that have won't
tell their best friends their age
because they're afraid then it'll hurt
their career ilysm how it'll get out
what do you think his story represents
because it's really it does keep you
going when you when those creeping
doubts about you're only able to come in
I think you know at the end of the day
cream really rises to the top
pure talent and and of course are very
many talented people in this day and age
especially and you hear them you see
them on YouTube I mean countless but I
think it's really and I hate it's a
cliche but I'm gonna say it it's really
never you know never stop believing it
really is never stop believing he just
kept at it or you can surround your
yourself and friends who never stopped
believing in you as well because you
know that's one good friend of his who
posted the YouTube you know no Gomez
really hats off to him because he never
stopped believing in her now so don't
stop believing yourself and surround
yourself with people who never stopped
believing in you
but really it's talent right he could
have gotten the gig and failed miserably
too but he has a good head on his
shoulders he knew he needed to deliver
and he knew you need to stay healthy
it's not just going up there and
performing for two hours every night and
that's it I mean health is a very very
big part of it and they used to call him
the monk on the road because he wouldn't
like he would not talk he would try to
stay really calm you know during the
when he was off stage in his dressing
room and really eat healthy and so he
just knows what it takes to get through
it and and survive and do it well he
knew he had to deliver it every night
for however many shows that
summer
you